salut à tous bienvenue au parlement
européen ici à bruxelles c'est parti
pour une nouvelle édition d' europe
hebdo
cette semaine je vous emmène en espagne
là bas depuis quelques années c'est le
nouvel eldorado des couples en mal
d'enfant la procréation médicalement
assistée est devenu un véritable
business et les cliniques privées se
multiplient mais d'abord l'actualité
quelques jours après un sommet européen
extraordinaire consacré à l'immigration
2500 personnes ont encore été repêchés
au large de l'italie alors l'europe fait
tel naufrage c'est la question de la
semaine
cette fois il en a fallu près d'un
millier un millier de corps un millier
de morts noyés en tentant la traversée
de la méditerranée
une fois de plus l'europe en effroi
condal s'émeut et se réunit et voilà un
nouveau conseil européen extraordinaire
une jolie photo de famille à la clé le
triplement des fonds alloués à
l'opération triton des experts des
bateaux en plus et une haute
représentante qui tentera d'obtenir un
mandat de l'onu pour détruire les
bateaux des trafiquants
quelques jours plus tard de 1500
migrants seront secourus en à peine un
week end mais on nous aura prévenu il y
aura d'autres naufrage d'autres morts
comme un sentiment de déjà-vu de déjà
vécu ce retour arrière octobre 2013 josé
manuel barroso ancien président de la
commission se recueillent déjà devant
des centaines de cercueils à lampedusa
plus jamais ça entendra-t-on un conseil
européen extraordinaire plus tard rien
l'attend
même le pape en visite au parlement
consacrera l'expression le cimetière
méditerranée alors est-ce le naufrage de
l'union européenne
1500 morts depuis janvier contre à peine
une centaine à la même période l'année
dernière est ce que la méditerranée est
un cimetière
et est ce que l'europe c'est un peu le
naufrage de l' europe sur cette question
pour répondre à ces questions c'est
rachida dati que je reçois bonjour
bonjour députée européenne ancienne
garde des sceaux française vous quand
vous voyez cette situation est ce que
vous direz que c'est le naufrage de
l'union européenne s'agit pas du
naufrage de l'union européenne l'union
européenne c'est une grande idée c'est
quand d'union c'est la mobilisation de
femmes et d'hommes pour cet idéal
européen qui aussi au départ s'est
construit sur la paye pour vouloir le
fait appel sur saône à l'heure mais
justement je trouve qu'il ya encore
heureusement il y a pas remis cette
europe et parmi leurs institutions
encore des hommes et des femmes qui
résistent justement pour comment qu'on
ne sombre pas et que nos valeurs ne
sombre pas et aujourd'hui je trouve que
le sommet européen a été a été
catastrophique je ne veux pas employer
des termes beaucoup plus violent que
cela et là c'est pas la faute des
instituts en pn c'est pas la faute de la
commission c'est la faute des états
membres chacun replié sur son égoïsme
national
c'est vrai que les décisions prises par
ce sont des européens rien si on
augmente les moyens de triton à quoi
sert des tritons mesures mais à quoi
sert triton faut que les téléspecteurs
téléspectateurs le sage qu'on on est là
en train de parler entre entre
professionnels s'il fut direct des
jargons que personne ne connaît triton
ce sont des bateaux qui surveille les
frontières extérieures de l'europe avec
très peu de moyens certes mais qui ne
servent qu'à surveiller
pas de sauvetage pas d'assistance donc
on laisse les gens mourir cirque on se
barricade et on laisse les gens mourir
dans la méditerranée en lisant ces gens
là n'est qu'à trente milles marins de la
planète c'est notre problème et c'est
notre responsabilité parce que ce qui se
passe au delà des frontières de de
l'union européenne ça nous concerne
parce que nous avons été co responsable
de cette situation aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs moi je je je soutiens et je
félicite jean claude juncker
comme aux courageux dans ses
propositions il n'a pas été entendu et
joaillier barroso l'a qui s'incline
devant les cercueils il n'a rien fait
non il n'a jamais rien fait et c'est un
sujet qui ne l'a jamais préoccupé donc
l'hécatombe
les images qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
des unions c'est tous les jours c'est
tous les jours on en parle quant au bout
d'un moment il ya un petit seuil
critique qu'on dépasse mais c'est tous
les jours aujourd'hui ce qu'il faudrait
t'il faire et nous avons les moyens de
le faire c'est d'abord de d'élargir la
mission de triton a effectivement au
sauvetage et paquets la surveillance ces
sauvetages et assistance
mais on a pu obtenir très facilement un
mandat de l'onu pour aller taper en ma
vie en libye ou en somalie mais on ne
peut pas obtenir un mandat de l'onu pour
aller aux frontières et sur les côtes
libyennes pour saisir et bateau pour
interpeller les autres représentants de
la essayer des les passeurs nous serions
à la source de ce terrorisme parce que
s'il m'avait allait faire des bureaux de
demande d'asile dans les pays étrangers
ça fait des années qu'il a dit ce
parlementaire par l'argument ça peut
être fait par exemple dans nos dans nos
instances diplomatiques respectives de
sur les ambassades ou les consulats mais
aujourd'hui et des pays totalement
instable la libye c'est très compliqué
d'installer un bureau là bas mais nous
pourrions déjà tahrir à la source c'est
moi je trouve c'est une faune nouvelle
forme de terrorisme ce qui convoie comme
ça les bateaux ce sont des armes
terroriste parce que c'est criminel et
pc pacers n'ont que faire de la vie
humaine
mais effectivement il on al'objectif 7
déstabiliser l'union européenne et les
pays occidentaux
donc aujourd'hui il est important que
nous puissions répartir la charge sur
les demandeurs d'asile entre tous les
états membres
ce que ne veulent pas aujourd'hui les
états membres et la deuxième chose que
nous ayons des contrôles aux frontières
et dans les pays sources comme en libye
alors justement sur la libye on se
souvient d'une petite sortie de françois
hollande lors de ce conseil européen
on écoute
il y à la question libyenne et si là il
s'agit plus de l'europe
si le monde reste indifférent à ce qui
se passe en libye alors mal même si on
met davantage de moyens davantage de
surveillance davantage de présence en
mer davantage de coopération davantage
de lutte contre les terroristes
il y aura toujours cette cause terrible
qui est le fait que ce pays n'ait pu
diriger il est même plus gouverné il
l'est dans le chaos et la question c'est
de savoir comment se fait-il qu après
une intervention il y a maintenant plus
de trois ans et demi il y ait eu aucune
réflexion sur ce qui devait se passer
après alors maintenant il s'agit de
réparer les erreurs viennent
rachida dati à l'époque vous étiez dans
le gouvernement et menait donc par
nicolas sarkozy président de la
république est ce que nicolas sarkozy
david cameron n'ont eu aucune réflexion
avant de s'engager en libye sinon j'ai
été réticente sur cette intervention et
je l'avais dit à l'époque
maintenant cette intervention a eu lieu
parce que effectivement c'était à
l'époque kadhafi a menacé de tuer plus
de 1 million de civils
mais dans les propos viennent d'entendre
mais qui est présente la réplique depuis
trois ans puisque l'intervention est
intervenu
il y a trois ans donc qui est président
depuis trois ans pour gérer justement
gars 3 c'est vraiment la commande mais
il ya un gouvernement il ya un chef
d'état qui s'appelle françois hollande
il pouvait prendre les mesures pour
gérer avec l'europe
ce chaos donc aujourd'hui on a une
responsabilité ce qui se passe en libye
et puis monsieur hollande a été invitée
d'honneur du du conseil de coopération
du golfe
c'est une première mais peut-être que
nous avons aussi une réalité pas
uniquement de vendre des rafale des
armes et des produits l'arabie saoudite
ou au qatar ces pays là on a peut être
aussi des comptes à leur demander des
comptes notamment en termes de
financement axé sur l'afrique
subsaharienne
il ya des financements et des
financements sur des organisations
femmes sur dix ans des reçoit des
financements privés du qatar d'arabie
saoudite du yémen
quand alors ça vous choque pas passée je
trouve ça choquant on a peut-être des
comptes a demandé donc aujourd'hui il
est important parce qu'allah sarkozy
était aussi un ami a révélé du qatar
dèche date de quand ça a commencé bien
avant
d'ailleurs l'état islamique en fait on
voit les prémices de l'état islamique
déjà après la fin de la guerre en irak
d'ailleurs la plupart des lieutenants
qui sont aujourd'hui à la tête de dèche
sont passés par abou ghraib sont passés
par les geôles américaines ce qui a
aggravé cela qu'est ce qui a constitué
en état n'avions jamais eu d'état comme
la dèche avec des ressources une armée
et à un territoire
ça s'était jamais produit avant celle à
port-blanc nous avions des organisations
terroristes mais là nous avons non
seulement des organisations terroristes
mais avec des financements est un
territoire où vous avez rendu il ya peu
de temps un rapport sur la fermeture
nécessaire indispensable de la prison de
guantanamo il ya encore 143 simplement
et humblement
une fois qu'on aura fermer la prison ces
bombes humaines
puisque c'est comme ça que voulez vous
les appelez qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
parce que dans ces détenus quand
guantanamo a été ouvert on était à 800
ou 900 détenus
aujourd'hui il ya eu une seule personne
condamnée sur ce tous ces détenus
et il en reste six ou sept qui sont ce
qu'on appelle en en phase pré judiciaire
pré contentieuse qui serait concerné par
les attentats du 11 septembre tous les
autres pas de charge aujourd'hui et ils
sont en attente d'être transféré donc
vous imaginez bien que même s'ils
n'étaient pas radicaliser avant ils
avaient trait de radicaliser aujourd'hui
qu'hier et aujourd'hui je peux vous dire
que par exemple
aussi bien le département d'état que des
ong ont dit que c'est entre 15 et 20% de
taux de récidive que ces gens qu'on
libère sont de nouveau réimpliquer pas
impliqués dans des attentats terroristes
ou dans des atteintes à des intérêts
occidentaux et qu'on les réalise
normalement c'est de trouver des pays
d'accueil pour où les pays d'origine oui
quand c'est stable quand on voit une
pour la plupart sont des yéménites
quand on voit l'état du yémen c'est très
compliqué ou sinon d'autres pays tiers
mais moi j'appelle aussi la
responsabilité des états unis ne veulent
point d'accueillir sur leur territoire
en disant c'est pour nous un sujet de
sécurité avant et pour l'europe
ils nous répondent pour l'europe c'est
un sujet humanitaire je ne le crois pas
parce que notre opinion publique ne
pourra pas l'accepter et jeu et je suis
d'accord avec cela mais faut aussi ne
pas oublier que guantanamo
c'est aussi pour beaucoup et notamment
pour des organisations terroristes un
moyen d'appeler la radicalisation et où
diane dire que de dire regardez cette
prison de toutefois il fait d'une
violation en violation des conventions
internationales et qui gardent des gens
sans jugement sans charge
c'est une atteinte à l'islam
vous venez battre je me bats à
l'intérieur
voilà donc il faut aussi fermer
guantanamo qui est en droit de ne plus
donner de prétexte
non seulement à certains djihadistes à
la radicalisation ou aux actions
terroristes mais ça fait aussi partie de
la lutte contre le terrorisme
très rapidement rachida dati
vous venez d'être nommé rapporteur sur
la question de la déradicalisation au
niveau européen
est-ce qu'on a les moyens vraiment de
mettre en place une cellule le moyen
c'est la volonté politique d'abord est
ce qu'on est
est ce qu'on souhaite vraiment lutter
contre ces phénomènes de nouveaux
combattants
ces jihadistes parce que j'ai été très
frappée mois par la conversation j'ai eu
et columbo guérini qui le premier
ministre y est irakien lui disant
écoutez aidez nous parce que maintenant
ce qu'ils essaient de déstabiliser alors
que nous luttons contre des shu ce sont
des djihadistes européens de retenez vos
citoyens et empêcher les se radicalise
et devenir une déstabiliser dans sur nos
territoires
donc il y a deux voie de radicalisation
à peu près majeur qui existe en europe
c'est internet et la prison donc nous
avons les moyens aujourd'hui de pouvoir
anticiper prévenir cette radicalisation
il s'agit dans ce sens d'internet moi je
demande à ce qu'il responsabilité pénale
qui porte sur internet dire que ces
géants d'internet doivent être
absolument bien faire les gendarmes
finalement en tous les cas s'ils ne le
font pas parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être uniquement l'outil de promotion en
toile tuyaux qui promeut l'état
islamique
les actions barbare donc il faut qu' une
responsabilité pénale engagée et des
sanctions qu'ils soient prises à leur
égard
s'ils ne font pas le ménage main mais à
écouter merci beaucoup rachat nous avoir
un petit peu expliquer ces thématiques
nous on continue sur quelque chose qui
n'a absolument rien à voir
depuis quelques années en espagne on
voit fleurir des cliniques qui
permettent à des couples notamment
beaucoup de français d'avoir accès à la
pma la procréation médicalement assistée
un véritable business nous avons voulu
en savoir plus c'est un reportage à
valence de cécile 6e
oh
je suis miraculé il y a deux ans c'est
ici dans cette clinique de valence que
le miracle s'est produit
juliette a reçu un nouveau site féconder
avec le sperme de son mari
neuf mois plus tard elle était enfin
maman d'une petite fille enfin car
juliette n'y croyait plus femme active
elle s'est décidée tard a fondé sa
famille compte cinq ans voilà on
m'attaque je vais y arriver facile et
puis ben non ça fonctionne pas donc on
commence à se rapprocher du corps
médical et puis là on commence à vous
faire contre 35 ans cette serre nage
quand même assez tardif pour avoir des
enfants
je voudrais mieux fallu verser entre 25
et 30 ans donc voilà ça devient
compliqué compliqué le couple s'engage
alors dans un véritable parcours du
combattant
on commence par des petites stimulation
hormonale avec des petits des petits
comprimés bon ça fonctionne pas on passe
à des inséminations artificielles à la
phase suivante
et puis ensuite on arrive aux pma j'en
ai fait huit au total
donc au bout de huit filles voilà j'ai
décidé d'arrêter parce que je n'en
pouvais plus psychologiquement je ne
pouvais plus est ces combats le fatiguer
j'en voyais pas de tissu positives 6 ans
d'acharnement et pas de résultats son
mari ne veut pas entendre parler
d'adoption
après un an et demi de réflexion
juliette se résigne au don d'ovocytes
ç'a fonctionné du premier coup c'est pas
le profil que j'espérais c'est pas comme
ça que j'espère avoir un enfant
maintenant que ça fonctionne évidemment
je suis quand même contente de mon
parcours et maintenant je reviens une
deuxième fois pour avoir une famille
peut-être à 43 ans la française revient
sur ses pas elle veut agrandir la
famille et tente sa chance avec les
ovules conservé par la clinique
franchement nul comme c'est bien le
mieux mettre aussi des couples comme
celui de juliette le docteur galop en
voit défiler près de 400 chaque année
l'espagne est devenu un eldorado pour
les femmes infertiles contre 80 90 % des
coupes que je reçois sont des couples
qui devrait bénéficier d'un traitement
français pas des couples qui sont hors
la loi c'est à dire c'est des couples
hétérosexuels dont la femme à moins de
43 ans qui peuvent attestent qu'ils sont
mariés ou qui peuvent attester d'une vie
commune d'au moins deux enfants sont pas
des femmes seules ou des femmes
homosexuelles ou des femmes qui ont plus
de quarante trois ans pour la grande
majorité donc c'était vraiment des
couples qui devrait bénéficier d'un
traitement en france et qui peuvent pas
parce que il ya un problème d'accès il
ya très peu de donneuses et donc les
listes d'attentes sont très longues
en france le don est gratuit et anonyme
et les donneuses doivent déjà être maman
pour le fondateur des cliniques heavy
josé rémory ce système est archaïque et
model of life est une offre le modèle
français ne fonctionne pas en espagne
c'est la règle de la compensation
économique
cette régulation doit être décidée par
l'état
de telle sorte que tout le monde
reçoivent une compensation à la hauteur
désagréments subis cola
bonjour comment ça va ça va merci
monsieur oui marta est étudiante en
médecine à 26 ans elle a déjà donné ses
ovules à quatre reprises sa motivation
et d des couples infertiles
mais pas seulement elle reçoit à chaque
fois 900 euros pour moi c'est bien parce
que pendant mes études je n'ai pas
beaucoup de temps pour travailler et
étudier en même temps donc c'est une
manière rapide de toucher de l'argent ça
me permet d'être indépendante
je pense que c'est un bon complément
financier consultation visite
gynécologique neuf jours de traitement
par piqûre et ponction sous anesthésie
générale
la rémunération vient surtout compenser
la lourdeur de l'acte médical pour
sauver l'économie comme la compensation
économique bien sûr qu elle la mérite
rien que pour le désagrément physique
le fait de donner ça requiert un effort
personnel un investissement et une
grande responsabilité
un don qui est si ça c'est pas comme
donné son sang ou par londres et deux
oreilles parce que le don d'ovocytes
c'est comme si on soumettait un cycle de
fécondation in vitro n'est toujours des
risques d'infection d'hémorragie et puis
à les récits sont liés à l'anesthésié
donc ces panneaux dans une compensation
financée par les couples infertiles qui
doivent aussi payer les différents
examens les médicaments les six jours à
la clinique et le voyage au total
l'escapade méditerranéenne leur coûte
près de 7000 euros le prix d'une famille
un luxe réservé aux plus aisés
et ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
s'offrir ce luxe et pour en parler je
reçois caroline roux bonjour vous êtes
directrice de vita international vous
êtes une association spécialisée sur la
bioéthique et l'audi blaugies vous êtes
journaliste au quotidien le soir bonjour
et vous êtes spécialiste des questions
de famille carole non je me tourne vers
vous parce que vous tic y ait un temps
dans ce reportage
c'est inadmissible pour vous de payer
pour donner enfin d'être payés pour
donner ses ovules quand on voit en fait
le bonheur vous à peut procurer des
familles qui n'y ont pas accès alors je
parle je fais de les quotas pour les
femmes qui sont confrontés à des
difficultés par rapport à la maternité
et bien sûr il faut entendre écouter
cette souffrance l'accompagné aider le
plus possible mais c'est vrai que quand
on voit des jeunes espagnols exploité on
pourrait dire un qui par rapport à leur
précarité de vie on voit cette jeune
étudiante pour payer une partie de ses
études
là ça pose question et je pense que en
france on pourrait se poser la question
pourquoi il n'ya pas tant de de nombreux
sites que cela c'est parce que ça
représentait un des médecins l'a dit
quelque chose
les loueurs de lure et on transmet un
patrimoine génétique mois s'est donné
aussi une partie de sa maternité
donc il ya dansé dans ces questions il
ya la question éthique profonde qui se
posent vous elodie vous travaillé sur
ces questions et la belgique on connaît
la question des bébés thalys puisque
c'est aussi une des destinations phares
pour ce type de besoin de pma ça vous
choque queen et finalement vous
personnellement ou pas je pense que la
grande question est la question
dérangeante à la question de la
commercialisation
c'est la question qu'on me pose aussi
quand on parle de gestation pour autrui
et je crois que tant pour la pma que
pour la gpa
il y a des façons de comprendre la
souffrance des couples et de les
accompagner de les aider sans tout
autant tomber dans la commercialisation
il ya des balises qui peuvent être
placés alors évidemment le problème
c'est que
ça relève du droit national et que quand
on est balises sont placés dans certains
pays on va dans notre pays
mais alors ça pose des questions
beaucoup plus large de ce besoin
d'enfants qui est difficile à juger et
il est difficile de dire oui oui vous
avez votre besoin enfants mais non on
n'en fait rien parce que vous n'y
arrivez pas
et point barre quoi ce business en fait
il est lié à quoi c'est parce qu'on a un
problème de législation européenne c'est
parce que justement belgique pays bas
espagne permettent certaines choses que
la france ou l'angleterre par exemple ne
permet pas alors ben parce que on est
toujours attiré aussi parler
transgression éthique par le bien des
skippers dont on n'est plus à une envie
d'enfanter par une construction la
possibilité de en tout cas ce business
existe et
je pense qu'il est nécessaire de
l'enrayer parce que on glisse
aujourd'hui vers cette marchandisation
des corps au nom de ce désir d'enfant
qu'il faut pouvoir entendre mais qu'il
ne doit pas masquer ni le droit des
enfants ni le droit des femmes et c'est
pour ça que en europe pour doit vraiment
il ya une prise de conscience européenne
et mondiale
justement sur ces pratiques il ya des
progrès qui sont formidables et en même
temps toujours les maîtres par rapport
aux droits de l'homme et au droit des
enfants et les double vie vous
considérez qu'il ya des dérives ou pas
oui bien sûr en l'occurrence en belgique
je pense que jusqu'à présent il y en a
très peu parce que dans ce qui concerne
la pma que la gpa
on fait confiance aux équipes médicales
que les équipes médicales ont une
déontologie très importante et je crois
que c'est un peu le problème aussi de ce
genre de sujet c'est que ça touche les
gens
quand on montre certaines dérives on ne
montre pas assez les belles histoires
qu'il ya derrière ça et les la grande
majorité des cas où ça se passe sans
dérive ya un besoin peut-être de
législation européenne sur cette
question ou pas parce que quand on voit
les disparités c'est peut-être ça aussi
qui pense au business je pense que c'est
utopique fin juin on ne va pas amener la
pologne à légiférer
sur la gpa alors qu'ils en sont toujours
à l'avortement quoi je crois que de
toute façon ça restera du ressort du
droit national et et que c'est utopique
ou alors on s'en doute que pour
certaines personnes ce serait une bonne
chose parce que je pense que si on
voulait les hyper et de toute façon ça
serait un minima et que donc beaucoup de
pays devrait retourner en arrière et
compris il ya un autre sujet qui fait
polémique
ici à bruxelles depuis quelques jours il
s'est tenu dimanche dernier un salon de
la gpa la gestation pour autrui à
destination des couples en l'occurrence
homosexuels petit florilège des
télévisions belges
autre titre je vous le disais un
événement polémique chez nous une bourse
de mère porteuse se tient ce dimanche à
bruxelles
un colloque organisé par une association
américaine pour informer les couples
homosexuels sur la gestation pour autrui
français c'est interdit c'est interdit
et on a un désir ancré de paternité
donc on vient prendre des renseignements
fait justement faire porter son enfant
par quelqu'un d'autre
ici ce n'est pas tabou même si le coût
avoisine parfois les 120000 euros
c'est utiliser la souffrance de certains
couples utiliser la détresse de femmes
justement pour pouvoir créer produire
concevoir un enfant qui va in fine être
achetés par des parents
elodie bleue visa a fait un véritable
scandale les gros titres les éditoriaux
les débats télévisés
pourtant ici la gpa est autorisée ça
fait quoi une vingtaine d'années il ya
eu combien de cas depuis 20 ans de gpa
une soixantaine une soixantaine
soixantaine d'enfants sont nés d'un don
qui est un épiphénomène mais finalement
tu as fait et parce que ça n'a rien à
voir avec ça c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est le problème évidemment
c'est que de fait ce genre d'événement
fait polémique
on en parle et on a beau parler pendant
le reste de l'année de la façon dont ça
se passe en belgique
les gens sont plus marqués par ce genre
d'événement je suis complètement contre
évidemment ce genre de pratiques
je suis par contre plutôt favorable à la
gpa telle qu'elle se pratique chez nous
c'est à dire qu'elle n'est jamais
commercial qu' il n'y a jamais ces mères
porteuses qui vendent ou louent tout à
fait tout à fait donc là ça pose
effectivement des problèmes en termes de
droits des femmes puisque on sait que
dans les pays que ce soit en inde en
thaïlande
là ce sont effectivement des femmes
précarisées pour qui c'est un revenu
substantiel donc on peut évidemment pas
importer ça chez nous mais je crois que
il y a une façon tout à fait éthique de
faire de l'agît père telle qu'elle se
fait en belgique où ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce genre de alors côté vite
international vous êtes quand même une
alliance une pause dans nos maternity
trafic qui ont manifesté contre ce salon
ce que je voudrais rappeler il ya ce
business mais il ya aussi en belgique
des réflexions sur la légalisation
il n'y a pas de chez p atrick 7 est
licite d'utiliser une femme si illicite
de faire un contrat autour d'un enfant
c'est la question
là on rentre dans les nouveaux types d'
esclavage insidieux et ça c'est vraiment
une question très profonde et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes très engagés pour
l'abolition la gêner
déjà posé la question à une mère
porteuse en belgique alors elle se sent
esclaves alors c'est intéressant parce
que souvent les mères porteuses en
grande bretagne comme en belgique sont
en général issus aussi proche de la
femme qui est confronté à l'infertilité
amusé donc par rapport au consentement
il ya aussi on peut s'interroger parce
que quand on est face à un service à
quelqu'un d'autre
après tout c'est difficile lorsque vous
arrivez de donner un rein pourquoi ils
se donnent et intérêts mais c'est trop
difficile au niveau il conserve son rang
d'être très libre si vous avez été
confrontés à des personnes qui sont qui
sont très souffrante par rapport à la
fertilité
c'est très difficile et on peut être
aussi très culpabiliser donc ça aussi ça
pose des questions et on l'a vu en
grande bretagne par exemple ou une mère
à porter l'enfant pour son fils de 25
ans elodie buisson
il ya énormément de filtres jédir
effectivement en belgique
vu que le don est gratuit qu'on n'est
pas payée pour louer son utérus se sont
de fait des soeurs ou des amis très
proches
j'en ai rencontré ce sont des histoires
auxquelles on peut pas rester insensible
je dire on ne peut pas juste avoir une
position de principe qui balaie tout
sans prendre en compte l'histoire des
gens et sans prendre en compte ce qui ce
qu'ils expliquent dans le cas du couple
que j'ai rencontrés c'est vraiment la
soeur qu'il ya eu une souffrance n en
ait qui a d'emblée voulu proposer à sa
soeur de porter son enfant et elle ne
vivait pas comme un esclavage ou tout
autre chose et il ya une série de
filtres dans l'équipe médicale où
l'équipe médicale est effectivement
reçoit la mère-porteuse éventuellement
son compagnon le couple d'intention
ensemble séparément pose des questions
et où parfois l'équipe médicale est
amené à elle-même dire finalement au
couple d'intention écoutez ça va pas
être possible parce que le couple
porteur la mère porteuse
sans qu'elle ne finalement ne peut pas
le faire mais à une culpabilité énorme
et n'osent pas le dire les compagnies
s'installent
beaucoup de ces cinq cas évidemment moi
je connais bien la souffrance de la
fertilité
mais il ya un moment où on ne peut pas
utiliser 30 tous les moyens et utiliser
des femmes comme si elle s'était
simplement des porteuses c'est oublier
aussi tous les miens
il ya à l'autre la femme et l'enfant
pendant toute la grossesse est créé au
créé délibérément des situations de
séparation de l'enfant beau merci
mesdames d'avoir accepté nous éclairer
sur cette question on continuera de
suivre ce débat qui agite belgique et
france et l'europe entière
non c'est fini pour cette semaine rendez
vous la semaine prochaine avec katia
builder si la chao
je prends tout etc